with the government shut down who's
going to stop
Al-Qaeda one thing at a time think of
the government as a broken down Carousel
just to keep this town afloat we
probably have to cut the budget of every
Department by 40 or 50% okay well but
Chris said that you just had to you know
Tinker with things yeah he said that
because that sounds a lot better than
we're going to gut it with a machete
okay what's a not gay way to ask him to
go camping with me effective tomorrow
morning the entire government will be
shut down until further
notice I'm sorry I just started hearing
really loud circus music in my head what
did you
say run hello Andy it's quiet in here
where is everyone the government is shut
down it's in every newspaper how long is
it going to last no for lucky this
building will be empty for months wow
that is really bad timing I just got got
this super sweet ass rad crotch rocket
I've always wanted one of these but due
to you know never having a job I
couldn't afford it until now got a
really good deal on my lease paying like
12%
interest it's like one of the highest
you can get all I can tell you is that
all the parks are closed until further
notice look no one is more upset about
this than I am not like it's a
competition or anything cuz if it was I
would win but that's neither here nor
there the point is I would win how long
will they be closed could be forever
with the government shut down who's
going to stop
Al-Qaeda one thing at a time school is
out in 2 weeks what am I going to do
with my kids all day keep them in my
house where I live I don't know what to
tell you what about the kids concert
tomorrow at Ramset Park the Freddy
spaghetti concert Freddy spaghetti has
been
cancelled the government has been shut
down for 2 days and one city employee
has tried to schedule 14 meetings with
me can you guess who Ben there was a big
concert now there's not isn't there
anything that we can do about that no
there isn't I can't stand this
government shutdown I can't stand this
budget crisis but what I can't stand is
they're canceling Friday's spaghetti
with current and projected deficits we
need to cut expenditures by 32% let's
make it an even 40 oh that's not
necessary slash it slash I am an
official member of a task force
dedicated to slashing the city
budget just saying that gave me a semi
right off the bat we sell City Hall let
somebody turn it into a large gas
station or a TJ Maxx Ron that is a very
creative idea but we don't want to sell
any of our major assets because we don't
want to lose out on any future revenue
streams I hear that don't worry I have
tons more ideas okay
uh so sorry
new ringtone don't cut anything without
me okay let's talk about parks and wreck
this one's a little complicated I know
it'll loosen up our brains massage train
and I know what you're thinking it's not
that I want a massage I'll be the
Caboose and Ron Swanson is the
locomotive and thanks to Ron the
services budget has already been cut
significantly so it seems like the best
option is job Cuts starting with Leslie
nope no no no no no if you fire Leslie
you might as well just get rid of the
department look I know how valuable she
is believe me but we've run out of
options there are plenty of other
options for example sell the zoo animals
okay to whom Cosmetics Labs weird
restaurants I'm just spitballing here
okay let's switch it up look she makes
the second highest salary in the
department it will go a long way I'm
telling you it's just not an option run
Focus up buddy wow looking good yeah I
mean I wish we' built one of those
elevators that comes up from under the
stage you know like a rock Arena kind of
thing they're coming what oh they're
coming what time what who the Russians
surely there has to be a solution Ben no
Ben says no I'm sorry
everyone
morning hi what are you doing here Ron
made me the official parks and wreck
representative for the budget
discussions that's only supposed to be
essential Personnel yeah yeah so shall
we get started I have so many
ideas Leslie's put together a
presentation for financial recovery
great you may find it very informative
let's get started with our first
slide well well
well this is worse than I could have
imagined the debt to equity ratio is
redonkulous what a hilarious word it
reminds me of a ridiculous donkey he's
the best what does this mean for them
they were in financial trouble a few
years ago like Pon was but their
government just kept borrowing money
Eagleton is on the brink of an epic
financial
disaster now that is the sexiest thing
you've ever said to me really that this
is going to hand me the recall election
I saved ponie from bankruptcy now I get
to remind people of that fact as we
watch our worst enemy collapse into
bankruptcy plus guess what I get to do
after the game now you pretend you're
ingred Let's Pretend This box is the
basket of apples I bet them on the game
I see where you're going with this no
you don't yeah you're going to ask me if
I like apples do you like apples we just
watch this movie two night I don't want
to do this how about them
apples you blew it super hard complete
buffoonery it's hilarious and you
deserve it hey you think you might want
to take it easy on them a little bit oh
like they took it easy on us when they
stole all our money and seceded from our
town it was 200 years ago cool it fine
I'll skip ahead do you have a plan that
will help us or not we have borrowed
absolutely everything we can from the
state and really Pony is our only hope
we do have a plan we are willing to
provide a bridge loan for
$50,000 25% interest compounded monthly
and you need to release a statement that
says that pony rules and Eagleton drools
well now you're just being nasty I
understand that our towns have a
complicated history but we have a saying
in Eagleton you don't kick a dress horse
after a failed PT to do whatever Blondie
your butler made your bed now you get to
lie in it and if you walk out that door
none of us here and I repeat none of us
will ever help you again oh my God they
have Michael bé on
retainer Ron we're
back bullly the bankrupt government of
Pon has been shut down all summer so
it's been three months of no work no
meetings no memos no late nights nothing
I wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy oh
rounding up the team so exciting I have
goose bumps
feel and that's why they call me Prince
Charming cuz I always find the glass
slipper for my Cinderella these are way
too tight well the real Cinderella
didn't have hippo feet Tom we're back
Jeremy suck it by the way I've been
giving away free sports for us of the
girls at Hot Dog on a
stick look we can dance all day but it's
time to step up are you buying 4,000
rubber nipples for me or not D you have
a
visitor we back we're back all
right Jerry oh my gosh look who's here
Leslie the nightmare is over Jerry we're
going back to work you're not going to
need this
anymore come
on I call a shotgun everybody heard
me